[Applause]  foreign  [Applause]  [Applause]  she said God what's his name  what's up what's your birthday  you gotta check me out I got you bro  we're gonna check you out again bro  turn your hand the other way  hold on I got it put your phone down  yeah  I'm gonna check you out  everybody proposing this  um yeah they keep calling the police on  me they got me to stand my report at  night  all right but unfortunately bro you got  a warrant so what if you like watching  high profile criminal trials True Crime  and unbiased legal analysis make sure to  subscribe to our channel for daily  videos I'm Dan Abrams and you're  watching the lawn crime Network